what's going on guys
so x-men Days of Future past is almost
upon us and that got me thinking about
mutants their powers which ones do I
like which ones are the coolest which
ones do I dream about having we're gonna
talk about that stuff today and by the
way today's episode is brought to you by
Norton who has teamed up with x-men to
help you take control of your future we
have a really cool panel to talk about
all things x-men with us today first he
is a writer director of NTSF SD SUV the
very funny show on Adult Swim Alex ferny
yeah she's been with us before a friend
of the show and you know her from Parks
and Rec Alison Becker thanks for having
me back he's a great friend of the show
been with us many times and you know him
from many TV commercials he's all over
the place on your TV Mike Carlson I know
so guys this movie it's chocked full of
x-men Mike who are you looking forward
to seeing I'm looking forward to Iceman
because I think we're gonna finally get
him like on the ice slide like flying
around which just looks fun I'm excited
to see Bishop his power is like if he
gets hit with energy he gets to then
shoot that energy out in the comics in
the future he was like had to hit he was
branded with an M over his eye for being
a mutant so he comes back from that
dystopian future to try and prevent it
from happening to prevent just the M
being put on his forehead I guess
superheroes they don't really have to
biggie just be like oh let me take this
Emma it's a weird-looking ham though if
you am on your face you'd be like oh why
do I have to do to get rid of them
Allison there's no plastic surgeon x-man
there should be another one power that
has been tapped into
my fixer Papa Professor Xavier says
let's welcome dr. 902 100 who is the
most awe-inspiring x-men to you let's go
down the line I think for me it's
probably beast because he's both a jock
and a nerd like his mutant powers is he
can jump around and he's super strong he
can cling to stuff but his brain is one
of the smartest people on the planet so
there's no way how can you make fun of
that guy Alison do you have a favorite
x-men whose power that you think it's
just like whoa I'm excited to see rogue
again because I kind of identify just as
a woman sometimes you're afraid to get
too close to people cuz you can really
hurt them she can steal other people's
powers which is pretty rad if we're just
talking powers it's gotta be Wolverine
yeah as you can heal so fast and like
all these weird aches and pains I feel
just like existing will go away oh man
what a super date or do you need to see
doctor yeah Mike is 76 years old so
every day not like when he loses his arm
deployed he's like oh my eggs
hahaha she could be a mutant what
mutation would you want to have I think
I'd probably want to be Colossus then
because you get to be normal just be
like a big hunky dude but then when you
need to you get to be a big metal hunky
dude and like I mean that's the best of
both worlds there you're not always
metal but you're always hunky like hell
yeah that's colorful haces rules he's so
awesome he's almost unkillable yeah yeah
and a strong communist ha ha ha
nobody's mentioned Quicksilver yet and
he is a pretty awesome power because the
speed is not only about speed but it's
about like a some form of like time
travel because you could get to places
very quickly faster than anybody else I
think that I would pick blink who was in
this film huh who has the ability to
teleport with like cool she has cool
pink like javelin she throws and then
like a circle appears and she goes
through it she's a cool elf lady which
is just cool is it super lame if if I
could pick one x-men power I'd probably
pick Charles Xavier power of a mind
control and I don't think it's super
lame I think it's short-sighted because
think about all the stuff you think
about on the day-to-day basis and then
you have to hear other people
that stuff I want no part of what your
brain right not always a lot of times it
doesn't leap through and all right let's
now go outside the world of the movie
and talk about in the entire x-men
universe what's like the most coolest
surprising or odd power I'll tell you
one that like it's kind of in one of the
movies the character showed up but they
never talked about anymore when gambit
first showed up yeah you can throw
exploding cards but a big part of his
mutant power was just charm he just had
a charm power but he could just talk to
you and you'd be like that's a cool dude
I want to hang out with this guy and you
just liked him that was part of his
meeting power now they never use that
but for me if you could just get out of
awkward social situations by just being
like this is who I am and I can throw
cards you could write every party would
be so much less stressed also you could
pretty much I mean there's protection
right there you could get out in yeah
there was cipher who his power is he can
just understand and speak all languages
also that's not a power yeah early
that's like yeah just read some book
like there's a guy that works at the UN
there's a real man who works at a UN
that has like that same mutation I'm
gonna say from the comics Domino because
she was just lucky whenever Powers was
just luck so like parking spaces like uh
I get every commercial audition I ever
auditioned for I think I already do yeah
yeah I could do better I could do a lot
better so which of the x-men would you
be find your mutant match at Norton comm
slash x-men I want to thank my awesome
panel for coming down here and just
having a nice time talking about
buting's Alex her knee Alison Becker
Mike Carlson excelsior
thanks for watching I'm how I can't be
up on Twitter my bike Frankenstein not a
monster
they call him Frankenstein's monster
well that's what the village is called
but it right of the day if he would if
he woke up and they just had like
episodes of Seinfeld ready to go for him
and he just sat him in the corner and
just relaxed his impulse would have been
to get up and kill something up
[Music]